foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is James page in Madrid at the ftth
conference event I'm here with opennet
CEO Maryam Sula baritze thank you very
much for coming and talking to us and
you're here partly to be talking about
difficulties of getting ftth out to
remote and Rural region so maybe we can
start by just giving us a little bit of
an understanding of what other
difficulties in getting out to those
those remoter areas
so thanks for having me so first of all
I think the
difficulty is the difficult terrain and
the low population these are the two
main factors that are obstacles for the
development of fiber optic Network in
rural areas so as you know the main
driving force for every business is the
profit and the Telecom business is not
an exception so when trying and planning
the expansion of the network or any
business is thinking about the profit
and this profit should be returned and
areas where there is no a lot of
population and there is a difficult
terrain and this difficult terrain need
even more investment that means that
this investment will be returned or not
so so this is the question for for the
business so such kind of areas are
staying out of coverage area so this is
the problematic I think the main problem
for for the development of fiber optic
infrastructure is these two criteria and
of course this is trans isolated into
the profits of this is the main problem
okay that's it's their problems thank
you for explaining them that that
everybody here at this event in
different uh countries is facing what
are any specific problems in Georgia but
maybe also a bit about the the way that
you're tackling it through open that is
is very interesting perhaps you can tell
us a bit more about about how that
system operates so as you know the
Georgia is quite
part for the problems I've mentioned the
main problem is the difficult terrain
and seasonality difficult terrain is
really problematic because we have to
consider this problem during the even
tendering process and construction
sometimes take 10 to 12 months because
of high mountains and during the
construction process for example our
Contracting companies they were forced
to dig very Rocky grounds and they they
were just supporting the ducts directly
on the very sharp Cliffs so this is a
really problematic and it needs
additional investment for the
development of infrastructure plus to
that this is not a surprise I think that
throughout the Europe a lot of countries
have this problem this is the lack of
qualified constructing companies when
we're talking about the technical
requirements and we're talking about
difficult construction process this is a
problematic very small amount of
companies can really deal with such such
technical requirements so this is again
problem for us because we are unable to
announce tenders for more than four
simultaneous directions and with the
project with the time constraint this is
the obstacle
and this creates some additional
problems for us plus to that in Georgian
case what we have this is the lack of
information about existing
infrastructure so what already exists
underground so we have to know what
exists underground and sometimes it is
not very much Clear what gas pipe or
electricity goes where and this is also
creates a problem for for Georgia sure
that must be yeah so you've got two
different problems with depending on on
location
um but you've got a sort of very unique
solution the uh the open net initiative
it's got two separate parts to it which
you could explain how those two
different parts work yeah so uh the
project that is called login Georgia
that is supported by the World Bank and
European Investment Bank consists of two
components mainly to components uh the
biggest component is the infrastructure
development that is executed by the open
net and where as I've mentioned uh we
have to develop approximately five
thousand kilometers till end of 2025 and
take into consideration the high
mountainous terrain this is quite an
ambitious plan
but plus to that we have the second
component in the project that is
executed by the Communications
Commission that is regulatory authority
of the Georgia and with their media
literacy department so what is done by
the second component this component is
dedicated and focused directly to the
Boost of use of Digital Services among
the connected population so we're openly
develops the infrastructure then
Communications Commission under takes
specific training courses and capacity
building programs in order to give
understanding to the citizens why it is
important to connect to the global
Network so they are promoting digital
finance e-learning
e-house and other e-government services
so this means practically The increased
demand from the citizen side increased
demand means increased profit from there
for the ISP so they are becoming then
stimulated to
uh use opennet network and to develop
Last Mile and to connect end users to to
the global Network so it's a it's a twin
track approach we might say because if
you're building the demand for the
service but you're also building the
networks you then want lots of people to
actually use the networks that are so
difficult to build absolutely absolutely
we have some house simultaneous effect
and we think that this becomes our
project a bit unique and this will
create effective results so we really do
hope that it will have really very
effective results uh well it sounds like
a really interesting way of approaching
it and uh from hearing from you to damn
sure it will be successful even if we
have some ambitious targets to hit but
um thank you for coming and giving us a
little bit of insight and we hope you
have a great day at the conference thank
you you very much thank you for having
me and this opportunity to speak about
the Georgia and the project thanks
[Music]
[Applause]